[Music]
hello and welcome to the week in 60
minutes
brought to you by spectator tv and
broadcast on thursday july 29th
i'm katie balls the spectator's deputy
political editor
and i'll be your host for the next hour
on this week's show
how should we respond to the migrant
crisis
more than 2 000 people illegally entered
the uk across the channel in june alone
a new record i'll speak to douglas
murray and the refugee council envers
solomon
and what's it like to make the journey
ara murren a syrian actress who came to
the uk on an american passport she
bought for 500 pounds will join us
turning to covet why are cases falling
so rapidly
is it all good news and should
epidemiologists resist making really
bold predictions
oxford sinetra gupta would be on the
show to discuss
and then to the royals harry and megan
have announced a full part book deal
is this really the way to put the last
few years behind them
and is that even their intention patrick
jefferson
he was private secretary to princess
diana will be on spectator tv
finally is winning gold at the olympics
all that matters
i'll speak to cath bishop a former gb
olympic rower
all that to come in the next hour
before we get going if you enjoy what we
do on spectator tv
then do subscribe to our youtube channel
you do this by clicking the button at
the bottom of the video
and then tapping the bell icon to make
sure you never miss an episode
ever again and why not subscribe to the
spectator magazine 2 while you're at it
get 12 weeks of the magazine for just 12
pounds and we'll give you a free 20
pound amazon voucher
completely free do the maths there and
that's three months of the spectator
delivered to your door and available
online for just 12 pounds
did we mention the voucher just go to
spectator dot co d uk
forward slash tv offer to take it up
now first pretty patel has introduced a
nationality and borders bill
which could see refugees illegally
coming into the uk jailed
and border officers given powers to use
force to keep illegal
immigrants away is this the right
approach and if it is
is it enough i'm joined now by douglas
murray who is
in this week's cover piece um saying
more needs to be done and envers solomon
ceo of the refugee council
douglas enver thanks for coming on the
show today
douglas to begin in your cover piece you
know that the number of migrants has
reached record levels
can you talk us through why yes of
course
everyone will be aware that this story
has been developing in recent years
we have seen across europe
in the last decade an increase in
illegal crossings
from principally from turkey and from
north africa into
mediterranean europe and we've seen a
trickle
uh in recent years of a similar movement
across
the english channel from france to
usually dover or around the dover area
in the south of england
and this movement has been a
political issue of a kind for some time
uh viewers will remember that in 2018
the then home secretary sanji javid cut
short his holiday to go and stare at the
english channel
and say that he was getting a grip on
this issue
this issue however hasn't gone away
however much
politicians stare at water and
we've seen a very significant increase
in the number of people
coming illegally in recent
months and it's important to get the
figures in some perspective
um the number of migrants arriving
was four times higher last year than it
was the year before
that it was it was almost 2000 people in
2019
and it was eight and a half thousand in
2020. now the number
for 2021 having quadrupled last year
the number for 2021 is already double
that
of last year we've already seen in the
first six months of this year more than
9000
migrants arriving illegally by boat
across the english channel and we've
also seen
the daily records for that um
uh exceeded with uh a high
in july of 430 people making the journey
in just one day
so this has become an issue which uh
which politicians
continues to pretend that they're going
to address
and continue to not address and as i say
in the piece
if they don't then the numbers will
simply grow and grow because
the pool of people who wish to come to
the uk
and who might be attracted by this idea
of a parallel asylum system where on the
one hand there's the legal system
on the other hand there's the first
across the channel in
in a dinghy competition uh the number of
people willing to do that
is vast across many continents in the
globe
and so i suggest it's a massive issue
that the
the government needs to get a grip on if
it doesn't it'll grow and grow and
become
worse for the government envir do you
think it's an issue that more people are
trying
and succeeding in terms of crossing the
channel
well it's important to put this in
context there are far
fewer people coming to this country
seeking asylum
than they were a decade ago we had a
huge
far higher number over a hundred
thousand at one point when tony blair
was prime minister last year the numbers
were down
to around about 30 000 and if you look
at the
the trend over the last five years and
as i say the last decade it's a downward
trend
nevertheless the numbers as douglas
rightly says
coming across the channel have increased
and that of course poses a ch
poses a big challenge for our government
and it would do for any government
of any color because when you have
people
coming across one of the world's busiest
shipping lanes
in very small boats risking their lives
that that is a huge issue and it has to
be
addressed but the context is really
important here the overall context
is that the numbers coming to this
country seeking asylum
over the last few years and over the
last decade has been declining and it's
important to
to recognize that
several several things about that one is
of course it's not surprising that the
asylum claims were down last year
because most of the world was in
lockdown
um and it's it's it's it's very hard to
draw the trajectory of the last decade
not least also because the
movement you're talking about of course
uh in the in the previous decade under
labor was significantly to do with
intra-eu migration
uh it was to do with the british
government losing control of the british
britain's borders uh in part because of
our membership of
the eu one of the things that caused the
british public to vote to leave the eu
in 2016
was the idea that the british government
would be more capable of controlling the
british borders after leaving
the eu than it was before so that's why
it's a particular political problem for
this
government movement migration ebbs and
flows
but if after a government has been
mandated by the public
with with tidying up its asylum and
immigration system and in fact
is seen to be losing control of it in
such a visible way
then i think this is a problem and and
just
one other point on this which is that
it's important of course to bear in mind
that this whole issue of the signal that
you give out as
a country the people who are trying to
cross the channel illegally at the
moment
have gone through multiple safe
countries before doing so
they do not have to come to britain they
are
choosing to come to britain they do not
have to pay the smuggling gangs
thousands of pounds to go across the
channel
they are choosing to do that and
choosing to leave
safe eu countries and if the government
in the uk
encourages that movement then as i say
the number of people who will like to
follow
is limitless because we are talking here
not just about people who are fleeing
for instance
afghanistan iran iraq
but as we saw recently in the surge of
arrivals the other week
uh people from vietnam for instance
there are people from sub-saharan africa
north africa across the world people who
are suffering economic deprivation
who would like to come to the uk and who
the uk cannot allow to come
and we're just on there um douglas as he
just
put across there but also in his cover
piece and talks about the fact that
uh the current arrangement uh privileges
those who can
afford entry can afford to make that
journey
and also encourages people smugglers do
you agree with that
look i think it's really important here
to understand the context
even when we had inward migration from
the eu
the main countries of those
nationalities coming here seeking asylum
were not from the european union that
that was a that was a separate migration
challenge this is an issue which goes
back
right to when this country uh and it's
and
and we're talking about it on on a very
significant day seven decades since this
country along with other countries
put its name to the u.n convention on
refugees
and conservative prime ministers since
churchill all the way up to david
cameron
have stuck to a very important principle
and that principle is that those people
who come to this country
claiming that they need protection
should be given a fair hearing on uk
soil and if they need protection they
should be given it and if they don't
need protection
they should be sent back and indeed
today in the front line in the fight
against covid if you look at people
working
in the nhs there are afghan doctors who
had no choice but to get here
in the back of a lorry there are people
who came from iran
fleeing oppression who are top level
surgeons
and indeed if you look across the arts
if you look across education
if you look across business there are
many refugees who are making an
incredible contribution to this country
proud to be britons playing by the rules
paying their taxes and contributing to
this country
in an incredible way and it's very
important that as a nation
we continue seven decades after the un
convention
to stick to that key principle that as i
say many conservative prime ministers
have continued to stick to
which is if you come here with a case
for refugee protection you are given a
fair hearing
um there are two important things to say
about that the first is
um just to address the
fiction that the arrivals coming over by
boat
from france are all going to end up
being surgeons doctors leading academics
and statisticians and much more it's not
the case uh it's the fantasy of the pro
open borders lobby uh that everybody
charles can i just say
uh okay so sorry to interrupt but i'm
not advocating pro boarders well i'm
simply advocating if you let me finish
please charles come on
you've had a lot to say um what i'm
advocating
is the un convention on refugees now the
u.n convention on refugees just let me
finish
please let me make my points i'm not
interrupting you the u.n convention on
refugees
is very clear and it upholds the
principle
that if you are fleeing oppression war
terror
and you come to this country you can
make
a claim for protection and indeed we
have done that for decades there are
many people across this country who've
come from afghanistan
indeed we we brought together refugees
early this week across seven decades
people that had fled
idi amin in uganda people that had fled
hungary in the communist totalitarian
regime
all individuals that came here made a
claim for protection
under the un convention and were given
protection what i'm advocating
is that we adhere to that by no means am
i advocating open borders because if
people don't have a legitimate claim for
protection
or need for protection absolutely they
should be sent back to the country
from which they have come from and they
should be supported to do that
i'm very glad to hear you say that but
yet you're encouraging the breaking of
the law and the breaking of the asylum
procedures
by advocating or indeed encouraging
the illegal movement of people across
the channel and as i say we have an
asylum system
convention you said a moment ago that
you hadn't interrupted me and you just
have again
it's extremely deleterious for our
country to be in a situation where we
encourage
the breaking of the law by migrants who
you then pretend afterwards are going to
never break the law again
and they're all going to become doctors
and surgeons but let's just address the
bigger issue
which is the fundamental one which is
that you know as well as i do
the un convention for the uk is a polite
fiction
it relies on the the the
of it not being the case that very many
people
are going to make it to the uk and then
claim asylum
the people you talked about who come
from for instance afghanistan have as i
say walked across
multiple safe countries they are looking
at
europe as a buffet that they choose from
not as
a haven to try to reach and it is
exceptionally important that we as a
country understand this
in the modern context you keep talking
about context let's address the context
the context we are in now is very
different from that seven
decades ago we have not just the ability
to see how the rest of the world is
living through our smartphones and much
more and people across
africa have these devices but we can go
and move around
much more easily than at any time
previously in the current era
there are people from across the middle
east the far east
north africa sub-saharan africa all
wishing to move to europe and
britain is one of the countries they
would like to come to one third of
people in sub-saharan africa polled by
gallup last year
said they would like to move they do not
want to move to the middle east they
want to move to europe they want to move
northwards now my suggestion is that in
that context
britain has to be realistic about what
our capabilities
are of providing a haven for the world's
poor dispossessed and much more
i think we are a small country we should
have
small ambitions about this we cannot be
the haven
for anyone in the world who wishes to
have a better life to come in and try to
make that better life here
it's impossible but as i say we've been
running on the polite fiction
of recent decades and i'd like us not to
keep up that fiction
and douglas in your piece you talk about
the need for a tougher uh
response in terms of the government's
response
what do you think they should be
considering a whole range of
proposals uh the first is they could
follow the example the greeks have set
in the last couple of years and simply
turn around the boats
in the channel that'd be much preferable
uh to the british coast guard
effectively acting as a wing of the
smuggling operation by
picking people up a few miles into the
channel and then firing them to the uk
uh they could try to follow the
australian president
and offshore people wishing to come make
sure that their
applications are processed elsewhere
than on british soil
uh because as environs in actual fact uh
once you're in
it's extremely hard for the british
government to repatriate is it's it's
all sorts of
reasons why they don't do it and why it
ends up not happening or being kicked
down the road
and another option is to follow our
colleagues
and friends in denmark who have managed
to introduce
numerous restrictions in recent years uh
to ensure that uh migration into denmark
has gone down by somehow
nine times in the last few years so you
know australia greece denmark these are
also very distinguished liberal
democracies they all have a fine liberal
tradition
and they've also realized that they can
hold on to the principle of legality
and of borders and that they can do so
without anyone but a relatively small
fringe of people claiming that they are
some kind of beyond the pale countries
and for which of those options do you
think it has merit
well i i think this is a global issue
very much in the way that climate change
is a global issue and of course it's a
challenge for every western government
when you have people who are being
displaced on the scale that we do have
globally today
you know millions and millions of people
being displaced through no
faults of their own and indeed if there
was displacement
in europe and europeans were being
subject to what is happening in other
continents
i think europeans would expect the rest
of the world to respond in a
compassionate way
too so globally we have to think about
how we address
this huge challenge and the challenge
will continue
no doubt going forward into the future
years into the future decades
and it requires western governments to
come together in the way that they're
doing over climate change
and to think about a solution that
reflects
the principles that that nations have
abided by and stuck to and supported
since the horrors of the second world
war principles that are about
humanity they're about recognizing that
we are a global community and we
we respond appropriately to support
fellow humans when they're in crisis and
when they're in need of support
i agree this is a global crisis but i
think that people talking about
britain's borders very rarely have any
idea of the global scale of it
when people talk about the need for
compassion and humanity
i don't think anyone is anti-compassion
or anti-humanity
i think these are very easy ways to
browbeat people into accepting the
breaking of the laws of the country that
they're in
it is not a british tradition or
anything of which britain needs to be
proud to pretend that britain is not
britain unless we allow the breaking of
the law
in our asylum and immigration policies
the fact that historically britain has
on occasion been able to give sanctuary
to really
very significantly small numbers of
people in our history
is a reflection that we're a small
island with relatively small resources
in the global scheme of things
and when people say that that we need to
come together to answer this i agree
with this
britain however cannot be uh the resort
of choice
for anybody in the world as they say we
have the example of people coming from
vietnam again the other day across the
channel
for anyone across the far east the
middle east the near east
sub-saharan africa north africa and
everywhere else in the world
where they are not having the life they
would like some people are fleeing war
zones absolutely the majority are
fleeing economic deprivation
and it is a very negative idea indeed
to my mind to pretend and to console our
consciences
by pretending in any way that britain
can answer
all of these problems we cannot what we
can do is make things an
awful lot worse in britain and in france
in neighboring eu countries
by adhering to a polite lie but it is
remotely in britain's gifts to solve all
of the problems that exist
in the world and as i say in particular
by pretending
that as well as the legal asylum system
we have we should also have a parallel
asylum system an illegal one where
whoever gets across
the channel first in a boat wins entry
into britain
i think it's a great mistake and the
people who have been encouraging it
will rue the day when this gets more out
of control down the line
it is something that will need to be
addressed and if it isn't we've seen in
the last decade what happens i've heard
all of the arguments about compassion
and humanity
made by compassionate and pseudo
humanitarian
figures across scandinavia mediterranean
europe
they all said in the last 10 years let
them come let us answer the the woes of
the world
and then it got way out of hand and they
had to crack down
and snap back of course they did because
surprise surprise it's not in denmark's
gift to sort
out the world's woes it's not in
sweden's gift not in italy's gift
and it's not in britain's either it's in
the world's gift to respond to global
challenges in the way that we're
responding to the climate challenge and
of course
it's in the world's gifts and and the
gift of of democratic nations to
response
to respond to this challenge and i'm not
suggesting that britain
opens it its borders i'm simply
suggesting that as a nation
we uphold a principle that we stuck to
for seven decades which is giving
protection to those who need it those
that come across the channel
are not all economic migrants some of
them will be but if you look at the main
nations that they're coming from they're
coming from
syria they're coming from eritrea where
there's a huge issue
with refugee camps due to the war in in
ethiopia and the struggle the civil
struggle in ethiopia
they're coming from iraq we know the
situation in iraq
and they're coming from a highly
oppressive regime in iran
we need to give them the opportunity to
have their case heard and if they
merit protection we should give them
protection in the way that we have done
for many many decades and the
communities that have settled in this
nation as a consequence
of our commitment to refugee protection
have made a huge contribution to this
nation
indeed if you look at parliaments you
could track back
through many parliamentarians lives and
families
those refugees that have come here
indeed our foreign secretary dominic
rabb is one example of that
and just finally on that i mean in your
work you uh
offer support to those coming to the
country
what do you think is the case when it
you know reality meets
what people have expected in advance
i mean the reality is all those people
we we work with
when when they come here whether that's
through so-called regular routes
or the irregular routes that that
charles is so
uh seems to be so angry about first of
all
sorry
sorry i i do apologize that was my
oversight it wasn't an
intended uh mistake sorry douglas
um those irregularities that people come
come here too
whether that's from afghanistan or other
countries what we find is is when they
arrive here
they are hugely grateful for the support
that this country is offering them
and they want to make a contribution
they want to
do right by this country and they simply
want to rebuild their lives
they want to do the best for themselves
and for their families
and they know that doing the best for
themselves is by working hard
and by making a contribution and i think
what stands out from research
bio and s and by other reputable
research agencies is that communities
that have come and settled in this
country
are often the communities who are
extremely hard-working who do play by
the rules
and who do pay their taxes and are
upstanding
citizens who want to contribute to this
community to their communities
and we need to recognize that you know i
don't want to have an argument about
what is true
and untrue i want to have an argument
about the reality
based on our work and you know i'm sat
here from leeds today
we're welcoming a family that's coming
in from lebanon from a refugee camp
today
they will arrive they will be taken to a
home in york supported by the council
and i'm certain that that family will go
on to make an active contribution
to their community i was reading the
other day about
the woman who leaves the concert and has
set up the conservative supporters and
friends of afghanistan
she came over here with her father in a
refrigerator
their only choice was to come on a
so-called irregular route
what douglas calls illegal roots they
came here
and now they're making a huge
contribution to this country and it's
important to reflect the reality
of those stories in this conversation
douglas ender thank you very much for
coming on today and if you enjoyed that
discussion we will be releasing the full
unedited 40-minute discussion on the
youtube channel and so do watch out for
alerts which you can get through
subscription so what is it actually like
to enter the uk illegally
and what drives people to take the often
perilous journey
i'm joined now by r.r marin an actress
and refugee who came to the uk when isis
took over her town in syria so our thank
you very much for joining us today along
with your dog jaco
which we'll get to in due course um i
think to begin with
you came as a refugee to this country
and i wondered if you could start by
telling listeners and viewers
uh why you left syria well
thank you for having me first uh yeah
for sure i left syria for
many reasonable questions thanks you
know um
it was a war in syria i'm already
palestinian refugee in syria i was born
and recognized as palestinian refugee in
syria
my city called guillermo camp city
which is isis could get there
and we had to flee to lebanon actually
first i wasn't planning
to come to the uk you know we just
deflect me and my family
to the nearest country
back then in 2012 and that was
lebanon and then because our situation
as palestinian refugee was
very hard in in lebanon you know
so sometimes we would be legal
and give us you know three months for
settle and
sometimes wouldn't be legal because the
government has
different plan so we were
you know stable so we spent
six years in lebanon you know being
legal
and illegal i could actually
find a way for myself because i was an
actress
then and i work some
projects so i could you know try to find
a way
to make myself a little bit subtle and
anyway then we had to return back in
syria 2018
trying probably you know the things
getting
better and like that and
obviously the things was getting worse
and we just faced very dangerous things
and personally i couldn't
be anymore there i had to flee
as much as i could back to lebanon and
even lebanon wasn't safe
for me so i had to leave just
and i left and i came here to be
safe for sure and can you just talk us
through the journey
to the uk um because what we've been
discover uh discussing uh so far on
spectator tv and then the magazine this
week is
uh crossings and ways to get here which
are on obviously the conventional route
and smugglers and i want you to talk us
through through your journey here
yeah well actually because of my special
situation as
palestinian refugee which is i don't
have passport
for any chance for visa or anything
that i i was actually looking for you
know visa or anything that
can get me legally to the country
but that was impossible because i had
travel documents for palestinian refugee
in syria
which is lots of countries they are not
welcoming
this so i had to deal with a smuggler
because i had
no way other than being
with the smugglers and walking through
four countries
actually to make my journey
so i dealt with a smuggler he
was living in kurdistan airfield
and we dealt to help me to go to urban
kurdistan
and from the walking to turkey
and then from turkey having another
smuggler and walking from turkey to
greece
and then from greece dealing with
another smuggler
you know to from greece to the uk so
i feel like i i wanna fled from
syria because of the dangers the danger
things
there because of the situation and then
i had to deal with
more dangerous people you know just
because
i had only this option to do this
anyway uh the journey had took
a month and 25 days to
be in the uk and thank god that i could
make it because
i i didn't think that i'm gonna be
survive through the jungles and
mountains and rivers
and why did you decide to come to the uk
was it always the uk that you wanted to
head towards um
you spoken about how there are other
countries on your journey to get here
well actually when i was um
10 years old that was first time i
learned about english language
as a foreign language and suddenly i had
chemistry with the language
and you know because usa and uk you know
spoke this specific language i didn't
know why
i was really interested of the language
first
then later on when i decided because i
actually studied law
before study acting when i study acting
as an actress
i decided to improve my language
and then the destiny just leave me in
lebanon to work with bbc
a project and bbc arabic and bbc media
action
so and i met the uh lovely british
people around
and then suddenly i met a nice man
british in lebanon too so it seems that
the destiny
you know lead me to the uk and
just to mention i came to the uk with an
american passport for
another lady so i got chance to go to
usa
but because i feel something i don't
know
like just let me go to the uk
because of my experience with bbc
because
i got boyfriend you know
because the language i don't know i felt
safe
i feel more safe in the uk than any
another country
and then once you were here how did you
find the process
of you know joining british society
well um it's not easy i mean
okay i just arrived i thank god i'm here
safe
but then just the process gets started
and i just
treat it as a number you know i mean
asylum seeker process is
i don't know but actually affect me
mentally
psychologically i try to be active
and busy all the time but because um
kind of educated person so i can i were
i'm very aware about the process
like it's not fair you know i mean i'm a
number
and i'm just waiting like others and you
know
we've got 37 pound per week i'm not
complaining
by the way i mean i know but
it's not like it's hard process
and to wait there's no one will tell you
how much
for how long you will wait no one will
mention
when you will be settled down it's you
know i mean
i just just wait i'm here but for me it
wasn't enough anyway i did my best when
i was asylum seeker so
straight away i volunteer with red cross
and another three
local organizations included refugee
council
and rotherham south yorkshire and i did
interpreting course i did social courses
because i knew myself
i've got trauma after the journey
the process here as asylum seeker
affected me i mean i used to be a
refugee
before for all my life
but that was first time facing to be
asylum seeker which is
really i mean i'm i'm sensitive already
and that i think affect me for a while
you know i told you i tried to keep
myself busy because this is the best
but then i knew like this it's
something missing about the process as
an asylum seeker
and because i got quite good lifestyle
before
so i felt like i was struggling a little
bit
and uh yeah but i caught up
i had to go up yeah and
i was asylum recognized as asylum seeker
for 11 months
you know i mean i did my interview
after four months and then i kept
waiting for the
answer for seven months while others
people
get their answer after five days or
three days you know
or two months so i i had to wait seven
months
to get my answer and i mean mentally
i was thinking what's the problem of my
case of me as a human being why
it's so clear i i came from the war
i'm already recognized as stateless
person you know anyway so
yeah i just moved on now i'm a refugee
now the government is looking at
toughening up the rules around
migrants entering the uk illegally
so it would make that the roots harder
than they even are now
how does that make you feel
well i do believe because i'm part of
that
process fleeting asylum seek refugee i
do believe that
everyone who put the life and risk just
because there's
no choice no other choice
i know the government trying to do
the best for the country i know that
i don't want to be involved in political
rules or laws this is not my business
but i feel sorry i mean
i feel sorry because i do believe a
human being
has has how can i say has a right
to live in any safe place that feel this
is safe this is the best
you know i mean why not
i just can't understand why not i mean
even because they didn't give any other
options
i mean for me if i had an option to get
to the uk
legally i would not say no and
just walking through the jungles you
know i mean
i mean i just had no choice and others
too
they had no choice they they are
fleeting
thanks for joining us arwa and remember
we have a special offer
if you subscribe to the spectator
magazine today get 12 weeks of the
magazine for just 12 pounds along with a
20 pound amazon voucher
free that's free muscle spectator
delivered to your door and available
online for just 12 pounds
and that is spectator code uk forward
slash
tv offer now to covert
to the surprise of many covert cases
across the uk are on the decline
could the pandemic really be coming to
an end have you reached heard immunity
or are people just getting a little bit
too excited too early
professor sinetra gupta from the
university of oxford is on the show
now sinetra thanks for coming on
ministers are taking
hope from the fact there is now a clear
damage trend in cobit cases
what do you think is behind it and is
this good news
uh well i think that of course it's good
news
because um what what it does
is it starts what it does is it allows
us to start thinking about
the different hypotheses about why cases
go up
or down at all and where we were at last
year
was a situation where we didn't have
enough data
naturally the the experiments hadn't
been done
to help us discriminate between two
different
hypotheses and that's where the battle
has been
over the last you know year or so is
um in trying to determine
which of the two competing hypotheses
is correct and what i said
you know a year and a half ago now
almost was really that we should be
extremely cautious about using
mathematical models to predict
the course the um pandemic and also
to make policy decisions because
what we have here now is from
various countries arise and fall
and interesting epidemic pandemic
patterns
and as i've said there are two competing
hypotheses
about why these are happening one is
that they're entirely due
to the effects of
masks and lockdowns and other
non-pharmaceutical interventions
and we've seen a lot of models that have
appeared to validate that but they don't
actually what they do
is they throw out a testable hypothesis
about whether these things work or not
on the other end of the spectrum we have
several groups including our own saying
that well actually
we have to also consider the effects of
naturally acquired immunity of herd
immunity of seasonality
and factors that are not related to
these
imposed restrictions the truth of course
lies somewhere in between
but both of these activities are
actually just hypothesis
generating activities so you know that
it could be the um non-pharmaceutical
interventions it could be
herd immunity seasonality only data
can tell us where we lie within
that continuum and what i would say now
is we have what we we're seeing with the
cases falling
now or this downward trend is that
the effects of these npis are limited
and the main drivers
are actually naturally acquired immunity
in the population or
to obviously now vaccine induced
immunity which is unfortunately
probably quite transient but it's there
the signature is there and
and seasonality and we've had a piece on
coffee heads
this week by oliver johnston the
statistician and
he has uh ultimately said that it might
be
too early to celebrate or not in a way
don't get ahead of ourselves when it
comes to making predictions
in terms of the uh where the third wave
is over because it could in a way be
peaks and troughs
and he's talking about a local maxim
compared to a global one
and something we saw in bolton where
cases went down
and then they went back up so do you
think this means it's too early to
really know what's going on given that
if we look at the 19th of july easing
that wouldn't necessarily feed in just
yet
absolutely not i think that what's
happening here
is you have and something that's been
ignored is that there is a lot of
uh there are regional differences so it
makes absolutely
i agree with oliver in that it doesn't
make any sense
to uh make grand sweeping statements on
the basis of country-wide data
so you know last year people were saying
oh there's only six percent
serious positivity in the country and
there are two things wrong with that one
is that
they were not taking into account that
antibody levels decline
very rapidly after infection and
more pertaining to the question you just
asked there is no point
lumping together all the data from
different regions
and our own work showed last year that
while um
people may have been highly exposed in
london for example
it was clear that scotland had not
suffered
the same level of exposure
and probably lockdowns consolidated that
so yes and not surprisingly that's where
we saw infections
creep up immediately as soon as
restrictions started to be lifted
so it's not as complicated as people
want to think it is now that they're
very
simple models only including um
interventions and restrictions don't
explain it
it is still simple but it is a
simple mix of herd immunity
seasonality and some
effect of these non-pharmaceutical
interventions as well as
a transient effect of vaccine-induced
immunity
on blocking infection now just to be
clear vaccine-induced immunity
is fantastic and hopefully long-i mean
durable
lifelong when it comes to protecting
against severe disease and death
but i suspect some of the increase that
we see seeing now
is due to the waning of the infection
blocking part
of vaccine-induced immunity
and i think one of the reasons it feels
as though
many investments have also scientists
and scientific advisors have been caught
by
surprise on the drop in daily cases
we've seen in parts of the week
so we've had quite bold predictions so
you had professor neil ferguson i think
just around a week
ago saying it was almost certain to
reach 100 000 cases a day
and there was a good chance actually you
could even get to 200 000 a day
now they've dropped uh you know below
50.
uh you know we're looking at 20
something thousand a day in some cases
what do you think uh has led that person
to make such a bold prediction
um when that is not corresponding with
what we're seeing now
as i've said over and over again and
then my whole um
involvement in all of this from march of
last year
was to stress that models are absolutely
crucial and invaluable
as tools for generating testable
hypotheses
they should never be used to predict
and also policy while they should be
used as a basis
for formulating policy they should not
there
they should not be treated as
truth in any sense so what we have are
different hypotheses as i said we've got
a hypothesis that lockdowns work and
everything
uh you know is is do all the
fluctuations we're seeing
are due to these mandated
restrictions and then on the other hand
we have this other hypothesis
that maybe they are due to natural
immunity accruing in the population
despite these restrictions
and only data can tell us where the
truth lies
i think the data right now are telling
us that natural immunity
herd immunity plays an enormous role
in a very important role in bringing
down
infection and we've seen that over the
world i mean
all over the world there are places
where uh lockdowns are
effectively impossible to implement and
we know that natural immunity plays can
even in those circumstances bring
infections down
now what of course we needed to do was
recognize all of that
and come up with a policy that was
robust to all these uncertainties
and what we suggested last year which
was to
focus protection on the vulnerable would
have done that it would have avoided
all the uncertainties um that models
have
in in terms of actually throwing out
real numbers
about how things are going to be so
what's happening now is not
a surprise there are different models
different hypotheses the data coming in
what we need to do now instead of
arguing amongst ourselves is just to sit
back and say
okay which of the different competing
hypotheses
do these data support it's a rational
exercise that should be executed with
calm
and without this idea that there is some
sort of conservation of virtue
here and that someone just because
someone was wrong or right
when it came to the hypothesis that they
are either a good or bad person
do you think then that perhaps when
we're having these debates and
particularly
uh with cobia we're hearing more when it
comes to these hypotheses
uh you know competing theories um that
there is a responsibility as opposed to
to be a little bit less certain in the
language we use um because it's
interesting because overnight nate silva
so
uh the famous u.s uh pollster uh who has
got many things in his right
right at the time but also some things
wrong has been quite critical of neil
ferguson's language
uh saying that uh you didn't have a
situation where someone is uh
so uh keen to say that they're definite
when you're doing uh predictions
um just because it is such a complicated
thing to do
it's not it's not complicated it's just
that
there is a confusion between hypothesis
and prediction
uh the models that neil and and
uh all the so-called mainstream um
modeling community were producing were
all um
generally self-consistent hypotheses
about how mandated npis might bring down
infection
so they in those models they assumed
that closing schools would
have some effect and then they fed it
into the model and
they showed that that could indeed
explain
uh some of the patterns that they had
that were had been observed
to that up to that point so what they
actually were doing
were producing a self-consistent
testable hypotheses now where that went
wrong
and people started treating them as
predictions
i don't know and it's not for me to
assign
blame on that but it was not right
that's
not part of the scientific procedure
what they should always have been
presented as
were testable hypotheses uh as indeed
on our side saying that look we think
that
actually a lot of this is due to
the accumulation of herd immunity and
seasonality that too is a hypothesis
so what we need to do now is all sit
back and just
say uh let's wait for the data to come
in
and then we can decide which of these
is more likely to be correct and in the
meantime
we need to follow policies that are
robust as i said to these uncertainties
and
also a cognizant of the huge harm done
by such measures as lockdown
and and these these are all simple
precepts
i think people are falling back upon oh
it's all very complex we can't do this
you can't do that
well we knew that you've never used
models to make specific predictions you
use them
to generate testable hypotheses they did
that
we did that now let's wait and see what
the data say
thanks synetra next harry and megan
the duke and duchess of sussex have
announced a full part booked ill
the couple previously said they wanted
to abandon royal duties to get more
privacy
is this the best way to do that patrick
jefferson who worked as princess diana's
private secretary
between 1988 to 1996
says the pair need to be less
confrontational he's on the show now
patrick thank you for joining me today
can you start by telling us about the
book deal
the news comes out in drives and drabs
from sussex headquarters
i think that that there has been some
exaggeration around the amounts
the amount of money that's that's
changing hands and the the precise
composition of the the publishing deal
i don't know how much of that is
deliberate and how much of it is just uh
um because nobody really knows what's
going on but there's definitely
going to be one book um and publishing
being the business it is i'm quite sure
that uh uh penguin random house
um have got it nailed down pretty
precisely what it is they're expecting
for
what is rumored to be um at least 20
million dollars maybe as much as 40
million who knows
and you wrote a while ago about um why
harry and megan ought to consider a less
confrontational approach to the media
now there's various rumors already
circulating with almost a year to go to
the first books publication about what
might be in it
but one of it is uh lots of angry
thoughts about the press
so do you think they've taken your
advice
uh taking advice is something that royal
people can
um really do on their own terms they can
take it if they want it and they they
can ignore it
um if they if they want it i doubt very
much if they're taking my advice but
uh the the the
the object of writing about them is
hopefully to make sure that some
um of one's own experience gets through
to the advisors i mean i was an advisor
to harry's mother for eight years and
some of the experience i gained that in
that time
is of some relevance potentially to them
it's also
um of relevance to people who perhaps
want to put what's going on in some sort
of context
there's a risk that it all gets turned
into just an extension of the
entertainment industry
you can see from magazines and
newspapers that the
the people writing about harry and megan
are not
court correspondents in the traditional
sense they're
entertainment uh and society
correspondence they
um have successfully completed the
transition of royalty from
from uh great affairs of state to
uh gossip and and hollywood tittle
tattle which is
um perhaps good if you sell magazines in
advertising but it's
it's not very good for the status
particularly the international
standing of the monarchy now you
mentioned princess diana and your work
for her
do you see any parallels in terms of her
approach
to the media um compared to harry and
megan's
well the most obvious difference is that
princess diana
didn't invest heavily in a public
relations consultancy
uh her husband did her sons have
she never did she never even had a
full-time press secretary
when we needed a press secretary
borrowed one from buckingham palace
for overseas tours and things so our
philosophy was that
people saw nice images of what princess
diana was doing
and that was the message if you want to
know what princess diana
thinks is important what she's doing
where she's going
look at the pictures and that is a very
effective way of
conveying a message if you have to
resort to paying
big money for top level
pr advisors news managers spin doctors
then you really ought to be looking more
closely at the message you're trying to
convey
the british people in particular but
this is a worldwide audience
aren't mugs they can't be
persuaded indefinitely of something that
isn't true so
if you're spending lots and lots of
money on pr you need to be looking more
closely
at the way you're doing your business
the stuff you're doing
the principles you're uh you're
upholding
and really the whole
concept you have of your own reason for
existence and why it is that you're
royal
and not something else do you think
there's a risk of overexposure
for prince harry not really
it appears that that he and and
megan are in the business of publicizing
themselves
it's ironic that on the one hand they
can claim their own privacy
uh and yet on the other hand spend an
awful lot of time a lot of money
publicizing themselves and the
the secret here is that and they're not
alone in this a lot of royal people
uh in my experience have the same
um dilemma in a way they they want
publicity but they want good publicity
they want the cameras around the press
around when they have something to say
or they're doing something that they
want the public to see
they don't want the press around and
least of all they want cameras around
when they're doing something they don't
want the public to see
that is what they mean by privacy it
comes down to control
they want to control what we see of them
what we hear about them what we
understand about them
and really our opinion of them
and i suppose when we're looking at this
four part series now we know there's the
first book from prince harry
there's also talk of meghan markle
panning a book
on lifestyle and then there's
rumors of another book from prince harry
after
her majesty has passed away
what do you think are the risks with
their approach to this do you think that
this is something where we've seen how
the british audience at least seemed to
be
turning away in some parts from uh
prince harry and meghan markle look at
her book sales for example but yet
in the us they seem to be gaining
support
yes there's no doubt that harry and
megan have caught the zeitgeist you know
the spirit of the times
um although they are both
uh on the cusp of middle age they
nevertheless appeal to a young
demographic
a progressive demographic a um one could
say
a feminist audience and
that contrasts pretty sharply with i
suppose
people like me his mother's generation
who perhaps sees things rather
differently
the the purpose is plainly to make money
um lots of money to be self-sufficient
to live
a very agreeable lifestyle uh
and there's no doubt they have to square
their own consciences between
what um uh they're prepared to reveal
and what the publishers and their
publicists expect them to reveal
one of the problems is that if you if
you spend a lot of money hiring a spin
doctor
then unsurprisingly they're going to
work very hard for you
it's like if you you know if you're if
you make shortbread and you get the
contract to supply organic shortbread to
clarence house
you know you're going to give them your
best shortbread if you are a spin doctor
you give them
your best efforts this is going to be
your career too so
um if you engage people like that
their interests are not going to be the
same as necessarily your right where
your royal duty lies
and how you how you manage that conflict
in your own mind as much as in public
perception
um i think is perhaps the biggest test
that megan and harry face at the moment
thanks for your time patrick finally is
winning gold
everything britain is doing brilliantly
so far at the olympics
but some said there's no reason to
celebrate winning silver or bronze
gold is all that matters whether it's
pride or money
is this the right approach cath bishop
went to free olympics in team gb's
rowing team
and she joins me now kaff you pretended
not won but free olympic games and you
won a silver medal in one of those
can you explain what makes the olympics
so different to other competitions
so it is the pinnacle for most sports it
does vary a little bit for
uh depending whether you're a tennis
player or a rower but for most sports
the olympics is the absolute pinnacle
it only comes around every four years
and of course this time it's actually
been five years
so you never actually know if you're
gonna have more than perhaps one shot
maybe two um okay some rowers have i go
to more olympics but you never know if
an injury or something else will take
you out so
it is the top level the whole world
watches and olympics in the way that
they don't watch an individual sports
world championships
and it represents you know their
exploration of human
possibility the boundaries that are
broken in front of us
all but with a hell of a lot of pressure
that comes with that
there's obviously going to be a games
quite soon around the corner and because
of the timings of this one
um but i wonder what you made of some of
the discussion this week about
uh what medal counts because
you had piers morgan who as far as i
know has not won an olympic medal
and saying only a gold medal will do
which some people have
were quite quick to criticize him for
but i thought it was interesting that
james cracknell
and also uh like you uh aurora has come
out and said that
when it comes to what lots of athletes
need from these games you do need a gold
rather than a silver or a bronze because
that's what gets you coverage it's what
gets you on the front of a newspaper
and importantly is what gets you
sponsorship deals um
so he said it may sound brutal but gold
is what it has to be um
what do you make of that so i think
there were two really interesting and
uh and key points to challenge there i
mean firstly with piers morgan it's a
very tired
macho narrative isn't it but gold is
everything there's only one winner
and i think you know maybe that was
suitable for the world a century ago
when we fought conventional battles and
and life was simple and we were just
trying to you know be a bit more
uh efficient in our economic output but
the world is a lot more complex than
than that in the 21st century we're
not trying to just beat other people
we're trying to explore what's possible
in sport in business in the environment
to solve issues of social inequality as
well as climate change
so a binary mentality like that is
pointless we lose
talent if we do that and every olympic
winner comes out of a great
race and you need to have more than one
person in that race for it to be the
thrilling drama that we watch
so i wish we would look and appreciate
all of the
you know the tactics that happen within
the race the risks the decisions the
teamwork
all that's going on within the race and
not just judge things from one snapshot
just that second crossing the line
because we lose out on the human story
which actually is what i think has us
gripped
when we've all been watching these
dramas unfold over the last few days
and i think with james the interesting
question there is what is it that drives
an elite athlete
are they there to get sports coverage on
a newspaper
i don't think that's actually the
purpose of a lot of elite athletes
it certainly wasn't my purpose i'm not
sure it's a really healthy one
either i think it's about again
exploring your your boundaries your
mental and physical boundaries pushing
your sport forward seeing what's
possible
and being part of a journey to um you
know learn resilience learn teamwork
demonstrate those skills to others
be role models you know in the way that
the england football team were in terms
of advocating for a fairer society
there's so much more that sport could
and should be about in my view
than just about how much uh column
coverage you're getting and
and how much sponsorship may or may not
result from that
and you mentioned the england team and
how perhaps the high profile that uh
athletes sports donor has mean that they
can have that reach
we see more political interventions but
do you think it's fair to say the number
one goal of an athlete though
should be their sport performing well
so i think you're right it's about
performance but then we have a debate
about what helps you to perform best and
what i think we've seen is that
sometimes when you over specialize on
your sport you do nothing else
actually you can't perform as well
because you lose perspective you don't
have anything else in your life so
if you don't win in the olympics or if
you're having a bad training day your
whole world falls apart and that's not
good for your mental health
nor for your performance over time so i
think there is this rebalancing now
about what does a healthy performance
approach look like that will both get
you your best performance
but in a way that doesn't leave you with
a lifelong mental health issue
um you know or other challenges along
the way and i think then it is
actually good for um a sports person to
have an identity beyond sport
again we see that real crisis that if
you fail and you actually think the
sport is defining who you are
then you suddenly think you literally
have no worth as a human being
and that's not healthy it's not right it
doesn't make sense
and again it doesn't actually give you
your best performance over time
either and and when it came to your
olympic medal the silver medal
how did that change your life uh were
you elated when you went there
were you uh did you see things
measurably
change in the coming weeks so
i had really mixed emotions i won a
silver medal and i was part of that
environment you know along with people
like james cracknell saying
it's not good enough you know first
loser only gold counts so
you know there was a part of my brain
that had learned those mantras and i
thought oh dear i've sort of failed at
the last hurdle
there's another part of my brain going
well actually i came seventh and ninth
in the previous olympics so
i'm delighted to be on the podium i'm
also aware and proud that i gave
everything that i had on that day
and there's loads of stuff that it take
with me afterwards so you know my medal
is
is beautiful i love it it's tucked away
in a draw but the things i take with me
every day
are the way i learned to work in the
team the resilience that i built the
relationships
you know when we get together we don't
talk about our medals we talk about you
know
all those just kind of incredible
moments of bonding the training camps
the dark times the funny times those
experiences
those are the things that have really
lasting value
and it's interesting uh when i'm talking
about that mentality of you know
gold medals or nothing um because when
you're talking about uh
mental health and being so focused i
couldn't help but think of simone biles
who
is the female us gymnast very high hopes
for her
she has um she withdrew from
the group competition uh after
performing in one act and
the u.s he went on to win silver now
lots of people thought they were going
to win gold
but the messaging after that uh the
girls look pretty happy with silver and
you see uh some of those young female
gymnasts taking to social media saying
you know
actually silver's what they you know
something that they are delighted with
and they're not going to have
comparisons of gold
do you think we're seeing a bit of a
shift in terms of athletes talking about
the mental health but also perhaps
being less focused or less competitive
in that sense
i hope so i think we are i think
athletes understand that in order to
perform they've got to be less obsessed
about the medals
sports psychology actually teaches us to
separate out the concepts of performance
and results
we can't control the results they depend
on things you know that we don't control
like how our competitors do or sometimes
you know referee decisions as we saw in
taekwondo so all we can do is bring our
best performance and that's what we have
to measure ourselves on and then when we
get the result we assess and think where
can i improve and
and go again and that's a healthy way
that gets you your best performance
stops you obsessing about something that
you cannot guarantee and so i think we
see athletes now talking in that
language
what hasn't always caught up is the kind
of media
the media and the commentators the
narrative who don't really understand
that separation
it's a separation that's also really
important in business in organizations
where equally business results aren't
within our control and depend on lots of
external factors
and what we have to focus on is all of
the things that can
enable us to deliver the best
organizational performance so
it's a it's a formula that works well
and i think you know those who start to
understand that
see the benefits and and therefore keep
going and
so we start to hear that slightly
different narrative where it's not just
all about gold
it's actually about that performance
over time within the perspective within
the context
within which that performance took place
and just finally and careful we have you
here you
uh you know uh were someone who wrote at
the olympics but since then you've had
quite a shift in career
if you've gone on to work in diplomacy i
just wanted you to talk us briefly
through
what inspired you to do that so
i studied uh languages and international
politics so i always had an interest in
the world of yeah international
diplomacy and and so for me it was
you know another ambition if you like
another area that i wanted to pursue
and uh you know first of all i got taken
off on this incredible journey of of
being an olympic rower and that actually
went on longer than i thought as i was
chasing for that best performance
um and then i was really fortunate to to
have you know something else to
throw myself into and i actually now
work in leadership development coaching
which actually draws on both those
careers
which were high pressure careers working
in teams
trying to deliver results and actually
trying to work out
what does success look like you know if
you're negotiating in a really messy
situation
then you know where are we trying to get
to how do we get all of us to buy into a
picture of success
that we can all connect with rather than
a zero-sum game who's the winner who's
the dominant who's the piers morgan
winner
uh you know gold medalist here that that
logic didn't help in the diplomatic
world either
and i think it doesn't help in most of
the worlds that we operate in
kaf thank you for joining us today and
that's it for the week
if you enjoyed this episode you guessed
it you should subscribe to the
spectators youtube channel
so you never miss an episode again just
click subscribe
button at the bottom of this video and
the bell icon to make sure you never
miss it
thanks for watching and do join us again
next week
[Music]
you